[Music]
over the past few years you may have
noticed certain apps transitioning from
email pastor authentication to just
email link authentication and there's
two main benefits to doing this first
your users don't have to remember a
password and two it provides a
frictionless signup process that makes
it more likely for you to onboard new
users one app that does this is open
collective and the possibility just
became available to finder base
developers a couple days ago and I
wanted to send to thank you out to all
angularfire BassPro members because your
subscription allows me to donate to
other open-source projects through open
collective and I'm very grateful to be
able to do that in today's video we're
going to use firebase to build our own
password lists off system which will
take-it users email send them out an
email link that will authenticate them
into our firebase app I'm starting with
a brand new angular app and making sure
that it has a router then generating a
new component called password list off
from there you'll need a firebase
project with angular fire - installed
and if you're starting from an existing
project make sure to update the firebase
SDK to the latest version then go into
the firebase console for your project
and enable the email link method under
the email password settings now quickly
taking a look at the app module you
should have the angular fire module as
well as angular fire often here with you
our firebase web credentials then
initialize the app down here in the
import section from there we'll jump
over to the router and we'll route our
component to the login path what's going
to happen is the user will initially
land on this component they'll get their
email link and then they'll come back to
this component with a special off code
that we can use to log them in depending
on your requirements you may want to
break this down into two separate
components one to get the actual link
and then another one that they're
redirected to to actually sign in for
the sake of simplicity here we'll just
do everything in a single component the
end result should look like this the
user enters their email address we
notify them that we sent the email they
go into their inbox and then they have a
link that will redirect them back to
this component firebase includes a
special code in the URL and they also
need to return with the same email
address that they tried to sign in with
for security
reasons and the way we keep track of
that between redirects is by saving the
email in local storage if the user
clicks the link and we don't have the
email address and local storage we'll
need to prompt them for it again that's
most likely to happen if they request
the link on one device and then try to
sign in on a different device in
progressive Web Apps we can handle this
with just a simple browser prompt and if
the user tries to enter an email that
doesn't match it should throw an error
so we'll build a component that has a
way to display those errors then if we
try to redirect the link again and this
time enter the correct email address we
should get authenticated successfully we
can start this implementation out in
that component type script we're going
to need angular fire auth as well as the
angular router then we'll jump down here
and define a few properties to manage
the state of this component first we
have the user which isn't observable if
it's null we know the users not logged
in if it's an object we know the user is
logged in we have an email string which
represents the form input then we have a
boolean that will flip to true once the
email has been sent and lastly a string
that we can use to display any error
messages from there we'll inject
angularfire auth and the router and the
constructor then we'll define our user
as the angularfire
auth state observable then we need to
get the full URL in the browser which we
can do at the router by calling router
URL then we're going to write a method
that looks at this URL and determines if
it's a valid firebase email wink URL and
if so it will go ahead and login the
user but first we need to have the user
request the email link in the first
place and to do that we need to define
some action code settings in this case
I'm just saying the redirect URL is
going to be localhost 4202 our login
component then because we're in an async
function and also we're going to be
interacting with the Dom I'm going to
wrap everything in a try-catch block to
save the email address and local storage
we need to interact with the Dom window
and that could fail with things like
server-side rendering so we wrap it and
try catch to make sure that that's a
safe operation this method here will
happen when the user clicks on the login
button and we're going to await the
promise
send sign and link to email which
resolves once that emails been sent we
just need to pass it the email string
and the action code settings that we
defined earlier after that promise
resolves we need to set the email
address and local storage because the
user will be redirected to a new
instance of our angular app and it will
have no memory of the email address that
was used and then lastly we'll flip our
email sent variable to true and if
anything fails in here we'll display it
in the error message so that handles the
first part of the process that sends the
email out to the user when they redirect
we want to confirm that it's a valid
link and sign them in to our app the
firebase SDK can parse the link for us
which we do by calling is sign in with
email link and passing at the URL that
we get with the angular router if it is
a valid link then we need to check that
the user has the same email address that
they were redirected from that should be
the email that's in local storage which
we can call by saying get item email for
sign in but if not we can just use a
browser prompt to have the user re-enter
their email address after the redirect
at this point we should have the two
pieces we need to sign the user in which
is the email address and the URL so
we'll go ahead and pass those items to
the sign in with email link method on
the firebase SDK and that's a promise
that should resolve with the logged in
user and lastly we'll clean things up by
removing the email for sign in from
local storage now we can put this all
together in the HTML the first thing
I'll do is show a success message if the
users already logged in because our
users an observable we can just unwrap
it with the async pipe otherwise we're
going to display this login template the
role of the login template is to one
collect the user's email address and to
give them a button to click to send the
email out to collect the email address
we can just add the ng model directive
here and then bind it to the email
property in our component type script
then just below that I'll add a button
that's disabled if the emails already
been sent and when clicked it will fire
off the send email link method to the
email address entered in the form that's
the main thing we need there but I'll
also go ahead and add another div here
that will show a success message when
emails been sent or an error message if
there's any problem with the login
process and that's basically all there
is to it you should now have a working
password lock system in your firebase
app if this video helped you please like
and subscribe and if you want all kinds
of other exclusive content related to
angular firebase development consider
becoming a pro member at angular
firebase comm you'll get a free copy of
my book as well as access to my full
length courses covering ionic and stripe
payments thanks for watching and I'll
see you soon